hello everybody my name is naya and i'm
the black female engineer
and today i will be walking you through
my
coding bootcamp survival guide ie the
six
tips i have for you to really get
through coding bootcamp
smoothly so let's get into it number
one the first tip i have for you to
really get through coding bootcamp
smoothly
is to learn html and css and
really really really practice it for me
i don't know about other boot camps or
you know
all that but in my bootcamp we
barely really touched on css and that's
honestly kind of because css is very
hard
to teach you can be a seasoned
professional
in you know the ui design and all that
and
you think you are changing the
background color to something and then
really you're you changed just a portion
of the page
and all that and it's really really
complex
more than people can think
initially to be completely honest and so
the more time you can get comfortable
learning css the more
stylish and professional your portfolio
projects will be
while going through the boot camp
process because again
it's likely that your boot camp actually
won't go in depth with it and so
now you have all these tools you know to
build a web app but
now the web app doesn't look good like
it functions and it works but it doesn't
look great i know for me i would spend
about half the time in my in building
web apps
half that time would be spent designing
it because css takes so
long and it's because of that constant
trial and error you think you're
grabbing something
but it's not actually being grabbed or
you think you're removing something and
now
you've deleted the whole styling for
everything so it's really really
important to
try to get as comfortable with css as
you can
and really put in that time and so me
i learned mostly through free code camp
and codecademy and
those i think were great building blocks
for me for css because
right after i got those fundamentals i
then went more on my own and started
just building static websites again and
again
and trying to style it and getting more
in the rhythm and so
please please please if you have extra
time between classes or
weekends or anything like that take time
building those static sites build those
again and again
and again seriously you may not think
it's important but
trust me it will make the difference
between what looks professional and what
looks half
done my second tip for you all
is to find at least two allies within
your boot camp i went into coding boot
camp thinking that it was
going to be like a bloodbath like
everyone is like the hunger games
everyone is just you fend for yourself
and you don't admit
you know any type of struggle or
anything no it's not like that
my class and i were extremely close and
we
wanted nothing but the best for each
other because just because
you you know succeed doesn't mean i
don't you know what i mean
and so you want the people around you to
succeed because then that only one
encourages you more to succeed but now
you have people that you can you know go
to for advice and tips
and practice and all that to help you
succeed as well
and so find at least two at least two
allies within your coding bootcamp
program that way
if you let's say miss a lesson or you
are
rusty on a subject and you just can't
wrap your
mind around certain topics someone who
maybe is not the teacher
could assist you in a way that maybe the
teacher couldn't either because
the teacher is busy you know instructing
everybody else
or you know with their own you know job
but
now you have a peer that you trust and
can rely on
to really just help you get through this
process and the reason i say at least
two peers is because
really just you know in case one you
know has fallen
or one you know is unavailable and
things like that because coding boot
camp y'all it goes by
so so quickly and i don't say it goes by
so so quickly as in
oh time flies like no i mean like it's
so intense like
you sneeze and you've missed a topic
you know what i mean and so you really
really want to
make sure you're staying on top of it
and so in case one is unavailable you
have another
but also you know i'm not saying be be
in one-sided relationships like make
sure that
you are being a good ally and resource
to other people
as well number three tip number three to
really get through coding boot camp
successfully and with as much ease as
possible is to
take your rest days seriously this i
know
is a tip that i know some people are
gonna be like okay like we want actual
tips like no
this is an actual tip because you are
going to get
burned out in
no time at all if you just keep on going
if you
don't take you know a day or two you
know whether it be a weekend
or take your evenings off or anything
like that you are going to get
burned so so quickly and so hard because
sure for seven days it was fine and now
you're ahead and everything
but by day eight you're learning a new
topic and your brain
can't even stay alert anymore
can't even be on for that much
now and now you're you're the one who
has fallen behind
because you didn't take those necessary
rest days to allow your brain to rest
because
y'all while you're resting that's when
your brain can
really process everything that has been
done during the day everything you've
learned everything you've practiced
that's when that happens and so by
cutting that off now your brain is just
never given that time and space to
really reflect on everything you've done
and now you're on you know day eight of
a new topic
and it's like it's just constant
new information being fed to it and it's
it's it's gonna give up
like it's gonna be like like y'all like
i'm done
i can't do this anymore so no seriously
seriously seriously please take your
rest day seriously
and i would say take about
three days within into your coding
bootcamp three days to a week
to see what the days are like
what um the schedule looks like in terms
of
either lessons or when you personally
have more time versus less time and all
of this
to really then establish after that
first week okay
when are the best times for me to take
those breaks i had peers
in the program that they had a rule of
they don't
work evenings they just don't work
evenings so make those rules because
other people will respect so before tip
number four
please click the subscribe button and
hit like if you like
if you like what you've heard so far or
by the end of the video if you like what
you heard if you took anything away from
this
please hit the like button and let me
know what your favorite tip was okay
back to it so tip number four y'all
build and burns now
what's a build and burn so you are in
this program you are going to
learn let's say javascript ruby you know
node
all the works when you're learning these
things you're going to
build certain either features or actual
apps or anything like that
with these languages with these
frameworks when you're
learning these new languages and
frameworks build
so create that feature create that app
and then
burn it to the ground burn
that sucker down and do it
again and again and again
build it and burn it and when i say burn
it i mean
delete that you know file and do it
all over again because the thing is
you'll think you have things down like
you'll be like oh wow like look at me go
i'm
you know doing da da da da da and then
you're just over here you know with your
keyboard and building this you know good
ish
and then if someone's like okay cool
delete it build it again
oh bet
and then it's crickets it's like oh my
god
what's the first step what's this like
how do i you will realize where your
gaps in knowledge
are and you'll be able to really pay
attention in those and really make sure
that you are honing those things down
like crazy
the only way you can do that is truly by
building it
then burning it down and this
is too it's such a
tiring thing to do because it's like god
damn like i have to do keep doing this
like i just
spent the last three hours building this
and i think i have it down like i'm not
gonna build it and burn it like no screw
that
y'all seriously you'll learn
so so much quicker by building and
burning it seems like you're taking more
time because
you know you spent three hours for the
first one then you have to build it down
and burn it down and then you did it
again
and so you see these hours go by like
six hours go by and you're like ah
like i'm taking so long no you would
have taken even longer if you hadn't
done that because
you would have done it the one time then
you have been asked by
a teacher or student to do it and you
couldn't have been able to do it
or now it's on the exam and you forget
certain steps
and now it's been three days and
you've missed all these different things
and that could have all been avoided
if you had spent those three hours four
hours five hours six hours
building and burning so y'all build
and then burn that sucker
down so tip number five goes very
closely with tip number four you
want to code along do not just
watch this teacher you know do
everything
and you know don't be just like oh okay
cool like that like or even or even
let's say
you are a note taker and everything
don't be
out here taking notes of the programming
that your teacher or your fellow peer is
doing
build it with them pull up your laptop
and
make sure you have you know vs code or
any other ide
environment or anything and be coding
along like literally if they put you
know
if x is less than y like be
literally typing those things in even if
you don't
understand it because there's going to
come a time
where now you've understood it a little
bit more but you're missing something
and so now you can go back to exactly
what the teacher had had done while they
were teaching you this lesson and you
can see
oh okay they did x they did y they did
this
seriously document everything code
along my coding bootcamp they recorded
every lesson and they made it clear that
their
screen recording and all that and it
would be the lesson would be available
to us
anywhere from that night to like
up to two days later but that was more
like more
rare occasions it was almost immediate
that
those lessons would be available to us
but
let's say that your
you know bootcamp doesn't do that or
anything ask the teacher
if it's okay for you to record to screen
record the lesson
and the reason i say screen record is
because we are in a panoramic
and i am pretty sure no one is going
through
coding boot camp right now in person
that's why i say screen record and so
your lessons would be
you know through skype or through all
that mine word through skype
not through skype mine were through zoom
so no ask your teacher
hey can i record this lesson on my
laptop
so that i can come back to it later and
everything it's important to ask because
i believe there are some you know
rules or regulations around especially
with institutions like recording their
lessons
or if you see if there are other
people's faces in the screen
you know recording them and things like
that but i
i'm pretty sure it's okay if you're not
going to be distributed
um but no just like ask ask and
just say i really want to make sure i
can access this later
can i record this you want to be able to
access
those documents those resources those
lessons
everything that is part of the bootcamp
you want to be able to go back to
even if you think you may not need it
later you want to store
that somewhere seriously it's so useful
store it somewhere if if the boot camp
itself
doesn't store them on their own and
finally tip number six to get
through your coding bootcamp with
the biggest ease in possible because you
know it's not easy
but tip number six is focus on things
you are interested in don't be focusing
on things that you think is going to
look good
on a resume is going to look good you
know
to your friends or look whatever make
sure you are
interested in it if it looks good that's
good i'm not saying don't
make things look good but don't do
things solely
for the you know clout you know whether
that be professional or
personal like make sure it's because you
are interested
in it when you're building your
portfolio projects and you know stacking
up that resume
it's going to be so much easier to
build and teach yourself something when
it's centered around something that you
find funny you find
you know interesting like one lesson was
based around
it was based around under like
predicting let's say the color
or the hairstyle beyonce was
going to you know be wearing for a show
kind of thing like that's so like you
know random and
if it gets you to learn what an if
statement is
then hel like heck yeah like then
make sure you're really focusing on
things that are interesting to
you because that's what's going to make
the difference between
how good your your
portfolio ends up being how good your
app ends up being because
now that you're interested in it you
will pour your blood sweat and tears
into it because it's something that's so
personal to you
not just some generic thing my program
started
with 14 people
y'all the amount of people that were
there by the end of the program guess
guess seven
in four months half the class
was gone was gone be and
so you really really need to just grab
at
any single thing that will make this
process
easier and make it more durable and
fun and you know just exciting
being able to tie it with things that
interest you
so no please press that subscribe button
so that you too can show
my videos to more people and we can just
grow this community but
thank you so much for watching this and
i will see you
very soon because the next time i'll be
back i'll be talking about
the things you need to do before even
starting your boot camp to
really make sure you can really start
running just from day one and succeed
and get that job you know for 2021
and everything so no thank you so much
everybody and i will see
you later